[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an meiner Seite ist Norbert
Lehmann für den
Sportthemen dieses montags
Gipfel in Sotschi der russische und der
türkische Präsident beraten über das
exportabkommen für ukrainisches Getreide
ohne Erfolg
Verbalattacken aus dem Bierzelt der
bayerische Wahlkampf nimmt beim Giller
Moos so richtig Fahrt auf auch wegen der
Causa Aiwanger
Warnung der UNO aus fernen Ländern
eingeschleppte Pflanzen und Tiere
gefährden massiv die Artenvielfalt
[Musik]
Millionen von Menschen weltweit sind auf
Getreide aus der Ukraine angewiesen
heute gab es die Hoffnung dass Russland
dem getreideabkommen wieder zustimmen
könnte doch der Vermittlungsversuch des
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan
scheiterte
russland hatte nach Beginn des Krieges
zunächst alle ukrainischen Ausfuhren
über das Schwarze Meer blockiert doch
dann im Sommer vergangenen Jahres die
überraschende Einigung Handelsschiffe
dürfen passieren müssen aber von der
Türkei als Vermittlerin kontrolliert
werden und 36 Millionen Tonnen Getreide
konnten so exportiert werden drei Mal
wurde das Abkommen verlängert bevor
Moskau im Juli Ausstieg Sebastian ehm
als der türkische Präsident Erdogan im
beliebten Ferien aus Sotschi ankommt ist
schnell klar putin will den Gast und
Garnen denn zu verschenken hat er heute
nichts
kommen Sie doch öfter mal hierher um
sich zu erholen
putin will etwas von Erdogan er will
mehr Gas verkaufen die Sanktionen des
Westens aufweichen und den Bau eines
Atomkraftwerks mit russischer
Beteiligung in der Türkei vorantreiben
doch auch der türkische Präsident
erdogan will der Welt heute zeigen dass
er der einzige in der NATO ist der noch
einen Draht hat in den Kreml deswegen
ist Erdogans Ziel heute ein neuer
Getreide Deal doch dem erteilt Putin
nach drei Stunden Verhandlungen eine
Absage
wir sind bereit die Wiederbelebung des
getreideabkommens in Betracht zu ziehen
darüber habe ich mit Präsident Erdogan
heute gesprochen wir werden es tun
sobald alle Vereinbarungen vorliegen und
die Beschränkungen auf dem Export
russische Agrarprodukte aufgehoben sind
heißt solange der Westen mit seinen
Sanktionen den Export russischen
Getreides erschwere kein Deal ein
diplomatischer Dämpfer für Erdogan der
kündigt weitere Verhandlungen an
in diesem Zusammenhang haben wir ein
Absprache mit den Vereinten Nationen ein
Paket mit neuen Vorschlägen vorbereitet
dass erhebliche Fortschritte beinhaltet
ich denke dass es möglich ist mit diesem
neuen Verfahren Ergebnisse zu erzielen
kein neuer getreidedeal dafür mehr
russisch-türkische Zusammenarbeit im
Bereich Energie und kostenlose
Nahrungsmittel Lieferungen für Afrika
außen vor die Ukraine in der Nacht Griff
Russland wieder das Umland von Odessa an
das Ziel die ukrainische
getreideinfrastruktur
fragen wir nach bei unseren
Korrespondenten in Moskau und Istanbul
zuerst nach Moskau zu Armin Körper
offenbar hat der russische Präsident
kein großes Interesse dieses Abkommen
wieder aufleben zu lassen
naja Vladimir Putin verfolgt hier eben
seine eigenen Interessen und die hatte
heute einmal mehr kompromisslos
vorgetragen ihm geht's um die eigenen
Exporte von Getreide und vor allem von
Düngemitteln denn da ist Russland
weltweit der groß größte Exporteur die
fallen gar nicht unter die Sanktionen
des Westens aber durch die Sanktion
kommt es dann doch zu Problemen bei der
Absicherung der Transporte und der
Beschaffung von Komponenten deshalb sagt
Putin er fühlt sich vom Besten getäuscht
und betrogen der Westen habe ihm zu ihm
zum Ausstieg aus diesem Abkommen
gezwungen das Ganze erscheint mir wie
eine Art Tauziehen an monatelanges
Tauziehen solange sich keiner bewegt
kommt in die Sache wahrscheinlich auch
keine Bewegung
weiter nach Istanbul zu Jörg Brase ist
die Rolle Erdogans einzuschätzen hat der
türkische Präsident schlecht verhandelt
also die Rolle Erdogans ist sicher die
das direkten Vermittlers zwischen den
Westen und zwischen Präsident Putin und
alle Beteiligten werden wollen dass die
werden wollen dass die Türkei diese
Rolle auch weiter ausfüllen trotzdem
hatte sich Erdogan heute von dem Treffen
sicher mehr versprochen vor allem weil
sich Ankara um die Sicherheit im
Schwarzen Meer sorgt man will verhindern
dass die Lage dort eskaliert wir haben
es gehört Russland greift ukrainische
getreidehäfen an die Ukraine wiederum
soll russische Erdgas Pipelines im
Schwarzen Meer mit Drohnen angreifen
darunter die Torx Stream Pipeline durch
die russische Erdgas in die Türkei
gepumpt wird es einen massives Interesse
daran dass ich diese Sicherheitslage
verbessert das beste Mittel das zu
erreichen ist seiner Meinung nach das
getreideabkommen dazu gibt es für ihn
keine Alternative erdogan hat dann heute
auch die Ukraine zur Mäßigung aufgerufen
er wird also sicher jetzt alles
versuchen dieses Abkommen bei dem er bei
dem die Türkei mit am Tisch sitzt
irgendwie zu retten
die Einschätzung aus Istanbul und Moskau
Danke schön an den Körper und ja Hase
die Rolle Erdogans nimmt heute live ab
19.30 Uhr noch mal genauer in den Blick
auf unseren Social Media Kenner Kanälen
bzw in der ZDF heute App
jetzt ins Bierzelt der Gillamoos das ist
ein großer Jahrmarkt in Bayern heute bot
er der Politprominenz verschiedene
Bühnen fünf Wochen vor der Landtagswahl
und einen Tag nach dem Ministerpräsident
Söder seinen Vize Hubert Aiwanger von
den Freien Wählern trotz flugblattaffäre
im Amt beließ die beiden machten das gar
nicht mehr zum Thema alle anderen dafür
umso mehr Jutta Sonne weiter
diesen Auftakt in die heiße Phase des
bayerischen Wahlkampfes will sich Markus
Söder beim politischen Killer muss nicht
verderben lassen daher heute kein Wort
mehr zur flugblattaffäre rund um seinen
vize-rubert Aiwanger stattdessen wird
gegen die Ampel ausgeteilt
[Applaus]
Woche für Woche Diskussion Woche für
Woche hin und her ich sag mal eins die
hampelampel ist die schlechteste
Regierung die Deutschland je hatte
Schützenhilfe kommt von Friedrich Merz
der lobt nicht nur den Freistaat Bayern
sondern auch für das Krisenmanagement
gerade in den letzten Tagen hat er einer
Aufgabe zu lösen gehabt Markus die ich
finde die hast du bravourös gelöst
großer jubelt für Hubert Aiwanger bei
den Freien Wählern
[Applaus]
er nutzt die Bühne diesmal nicht um sich
wieder als Opfer einer Schmutzkampagne
darzustellen stattdessen Freude über den
großen Zuspruch seiner Anhänger
für diese Rückenstärkung dafür dass sie
auch in diesen schwierigen Zeiten mit
uns diesen Weg für Bayern für
vernünftige Politik geht kein Duell also
zwischen Söder und Aiwanger über das was
in Bayern regelrecht ein politisches
Beben verursacht hat dagegen Schafe
Kritik von den Oppositionsparteien
Hubert Aiwanger hätte sich hinstellen
können und sagen jawohl ich habe in
meiner Jugend Scheiße gebaut es tut mir
leid ich schäme mich dafür und dass er
jetzt umso mehr weiß wie wichtig es ist
junge Menschen vor den Verführungen
rechts und Linksextremisten von links
und Rechtsextremisten zu bewahren aber
das hat er eben nicht getan das ist
unanständig da wird der politische
Diskurs verschoben da verschwindet
Anstand aus der Politik liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde es geht hier um
Grundsätzliches um den Umgang mit
unserer Erinnerungskultur und in
demokratischen Konsens die AFD mit ihrer
Gast redenerin Alice Weidel hat vor
allem die Ampelkoalition auf dem Kika
aber auch Bayerns Ministerpräsident sein
Fett weg
CSU und Freie Wähler haben auf dem
politischen gilamos die flugblattaffäre
unter den Tisch gekehrt spätestens am
Donnerstag müssen sie sich aber wieder
damit befassen bei der Sondersitzung der
Oppositionsparteien im Bayerischen
Landtag
[Applaus]
zur Wirtschaft nach drei Monaten im Plus
sind deutschlandsexporte im Juli
zurückgegangen das belegenzahlen des
Statistischen Bundesamts im Vergleich
zum Juni sanken die Exporte um 0,9% auf
rund 130 Milliarden Euro die größten
Abnehmer deutscher waren waren andere
EU-Mitgliedstaaten die Importe legten
dagegen um 1,4 Prozent zu auf rund
114 Milliarden Euro das meiste kam
erneut aus China
aus China kommen auch verhältnismäßig
günstige Elektroautos die sich gut
verkaufen erstmals sind die Chinesen
auch auf der mobilitätsmesse IAA in
München stark vertreten die deutschen
Hersteller fahren zwar Rekordgewinne ein
müssen sich aber fragen wie sie in
Zukunft mithalten wollen aus München
Peter Aumeier und Alexander Pohl
sie haben Namen wie by D oder Neo vor
Jahren kannten diese Autofirmen nur
Insider jetzt erobern sie den
europäischen Markt kleine Elektroautos
10.000 € billiger als vergleichbare
deutsche Modelle
wir merken dass die Chinesen in den
letzten Jahren das Auto bauen gelernt
haben sie haben eine erhebliche
Geschwindigkeit wenn es darum geht
digitalisierte Lösungen ins Fahrzeug zu
bringen schon vor Eröffnung prägen
chinesische Unternehmen das Bild der IAA
in München legen die Schwächen der
deutschen Hersteller bei der E-Mobilität
offen sieht man das die deutschen z.B zu
langsam sind ja die Chinese bringt
wahrscheinlich in einer halben Zeit ein
neues Auto an den Markt was auch besser
vernetzt ist als das Autohaus deutsche
Produktion und nimmt uns im Moment
tatsächlich so ein bisschen die Mutter
vom Brot die europäische authentust die
erlebe einen perfekten Sturm also ein
Katastrophenszenario sagen Experten mit
Folgen seit 2019 haben europäische
Hersteller 6 %. Marktanteil auf ihrem
Heimatmarkt verloren auf dem
chinesischen Markt Sankt der Anteil der
Europäer um 5% Punkte bei allem was ein
Auto teuer macht Batterie Zellen und
Halbleiter können chinesische Firmen
deutlich billiger produzieren zumal die
ich hoffe im eigenen Land gefördert
werden die deutschen Premium-Hersteller
setzen dagegen auf Exklusivität und
rechtfertigen damit den höheren Preis
wir fokussieren auf das was die
Mercedes-Kunden von uns erwarten und das
ist die perfekte Symbiose zwischen
einerseits Innovation und Technologie
und andererseits zeitlosen schönen
Design morgen wird Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz die IAA mobility offiziell
eröffnen
in Deutschland gibt es immer mehr Tiere
und Pflanzen die es früher hier nicht
gab diese invasiven Arten sind eine
immer schlimmere Plage und spielen eine
Schlüsselrolle beim weltweiten Arten
sterben warnen heute die UN Beispiel der
nordamerikanische Ochsenfrosch wo er
auftaucht verdrängt der Allesfresser den
heimischen Wasserfrosch oder der Japan
Käfer der ganze Felder abfrisst oder die
asiatische Hornisse die großen Appetit
auf Honigbienen hat auch invasive
Pflanzenarten sind hoch problematisch
zeigt Andreas Stamm
Schwerstarbeit für die Truppe vom
Naturschutzbund NABU Ihr Auftrag den
Hirschacker nach Heidelberg vom fiesen
Gestrüpp befreien der spät blühenden
Traubenkirsche die muss raus um jeden
Preis unter Schweiß mit Verlusten
spürst du richtig auf dem Griff weil
wenn es dann richtig einschlägt dass wir
auf Stein klopfen
eingeschleppt aus Nordamerika als
Zierpflanze verbreitet sich das Gewächs
ungestört giftige Blätter bedeutet keine
Fressfeinde so zerstört die bis zu 20 m
hohe Traubenkirsche die Artenvielfalt
diese Pflanze verdrängt andere Pflanzen
indem sie quasi die Fläche durch erlaubt
hier sind ganz kleine
Gras das ist eine Art die man hier
schützen will im Naturschutzgebiet davor
ausgerottet zu werden eine Million
Tieren Pflanzenarten sind vom Aussterben
bedroht ein Hauptgrund zu der in Bonn
vorgestellte Bericht des weltbio
diversitätsrates durch Handel und Reisen
eingeschleppte invasive Arten die das
ökolog frische Gleichgewicht zerstören
wir haben zum Beispiel festgestellt dass
in 60 Prozent aller Fälle wo Tiere
global ausgestorben sind invasive Arten
einer der haupttreiber war
3.500 gebietsfremde schädliche Spezies
gibt es weltweit etwa 100 davon in
Deutschland der Schaden für die globale
Wirtschaft jährlich rund 400 Milliarden
Euro die Beseitigung ist wie nah
Heidelberg mühsam der Schaden groß der
vorgelegte Bericht dreht zu strengen
Einfuhr und Zollkontrollen Aufklärung
natürliche Fressfeinde aussetzen oder
per Hand bekämpfen Lösungen gibt es so
die Experten doch noch werde weltweit zu
wenig getan
jetzt zu einem Tier das in Deutschland
zwar heimisch Landwirten aber häufig
einen Dorn im Auge ist der Wolf der
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke will den
Abschuss von Wölfen erleichtern beide
Tiere wie Schafe sollten so besser
geschützt werden sagte sie der Zeitung
die Welt bis Ende des Monats will die
Grünen Politikerin konkrete Vorschläge
vorlegen auch die EU-Kommission will die
strengen Schutzgesetze für Wölfe prüfen
die deutschen Hautärzte fordern eine
staatlich organisierte Hautkrebsvorsorge
dadurch würden alle bevölkerungs- und
Risikogruppen erreicht teilte der
Berufsverband Deutscher Dermatologen mit
heißt die Behörden müssten gut 35
Millionen Versicherte anschreiben und
zum kostenlosen Screening einladen
zurzeit können gesetzlich Versicherte
über 35 alle zwei Jahre zur kostenlose
Vorsorge auf eigene Initiative
im schwedischen Malmö ist es nach einer
weiteren Koranverbrennung zur
gewaltsamen Ausschreitungen gekommen
dutzende Autos gingen in Flammen auf in
einem migrantisch geprägten Stadtviertel
flogen Steine auf Polizisten es gab
mehrere Festnahmen ein Exil Iraker hatte
zuvor in der Innenstadt eine Ausgabe des
Koran verbrannt erst derzeit für die
meisten ähnlichen Aktionen in Schweden
verantwortlich
wenn wir hier in Deutschland einen
sonnigen Spätsommertag haben sie z in
Teilen Spaniens so aus Zerstörung durch
Starkregen auch kahnböen Hagel und
Gewitter mindestens vier Menschen sind
ums Leben gekommen mehrere gelten noch
als vermisst die Schäden sind
beträchtlich Thomas Walde berichtet
in Villa Manta einer Dreiviertelstunde
von Madrid entfernt suchten
Rettungskräfte heute nach einem
vermissten
aber der Mann wurde vom Wasser
fortgerissen jetzt suchen sie nach ihm
und können ihn nicht finden
durch viele Orte wie Toledo flossen
zuvor Wassermassen in einigen Fällen
kann man die Rettungskräfte zu spät
insgesamt starben mindestens vier
Menschen
im Großraum Madrid verzeichneten
Hilfskräfte 12 Einsätze die Behörden
hatten die Menschen frühzeitig
aufgefordert Häuser nicht zu verlassen
für die meisten lief es glimpflich ab
wenn die Tunnel voller Wasser sind kommt
man nicht durch heute ist es schwierig
sich vorzubewegen sehr schwierig
diese Madrid der U-Bahn wurde beinahe
zum U-Boot in der Gemeinde an der
fressno stürzte eine Brücke ein laut
Wetterbehörde war ganz Spanien mit
Ausnahme der Inseln von Starkregen und
Überschwemmungen betroffen mit unter
vielen 200 Liter pro Quadratmeter heute
beruhigte sich die Lage
heute vor genau 25 Jahren wurde in
Kalifornien die Suchmaschine Google
gegründet aus unserem Alltag ist sie
fast nicht mehr wegzudenken Google
verarbeitet rund 100.000 Suchanfragen
pro Sekunde und ist mit 92% Marktanteil
die meist genutzte Suchmaschine der Welt
das Wort googeln steht seit 2004 sogar
im Duden inzwischen ist Google weitaus
mehr als eine Suchmaschine ein Tag
Gigant mit unglaublicher macht wie
Benjamin Daniel berichtet
in dieser Garage hat alles begonnen
klassischer Staat einer beispiellosen
Silicon Valley Erfolgsgeschichte
auf einmal alles viel einfacher und
schneller zu finden
es hat die Welt verändert indem es all
das Wissen strukturiert und auffindbar
gemacht hat
Google einer der wertvollsten Konzerne
der Welt
Jahresumsatz
2022-280 Milliarden Dollar aus Garagen
wurden gigantische komplexe aus
Tastaturen Touchscreens aus grauen
Sitzungsräumen moderne meeting
in jeder Ecke der Erde will der Konzern
Internet bringen er lässt Drohnen
entwickeln die Pakete liefern oder
Kontaktlinsen die den Blutzuckerspiegel
messen einstige Utopien werden greifbar
der multimilladenkonzern hat unser
Streben nach Wissen revolutioniert den
Preis dafür zahlen wir mit unseren Daten
google wertet sie aus macht Milliarden
mit ihnen wird immer mächtiger zu
mächtig finden viele nicht nur in Europa
der Vorwurf Intransparenz beispielsweise
was Deals mit anderen wie Apple angeht
google ist immer noch die
Standardsuchmaschine auf iPhones allein
das beschäftigt die Gerichte und das
Justizministerium intensiv denn niemand
kennt die Hintergründe solcher Deals die
dazu führen dass Konkurrenzfirmen keine
Chance haben mitzumischen Google Energie
gigantische Geldmaschine ihr wichtigster
rohstoffnutzerdaten und Profile eine
Quelle die unerschöpflich weitersprudelt
und solange niemand die Macht des
Unternehmens deutlich einschränkt wird
es fortfahren mit seiner Vermessung der
digitalen Welt
wer heute Olaf Scholz googelt dürfte
überrascht sein der Kanzler war am
Samstag beim Joggen gestürzt und hatte
sich im Gesicht verletzt jetzt
veröffentlichte das Bundeskanzleramt ein
Foto und versucht es mit Humor
wer den Schaden hat heißt es auf das
Kanzlers Social Media Kanälen ist sehr
schlimme aus als es ist und er Scholz
sei gespannt auf die memes also auf das
was die Internetgemeinde aus dem
augenklappenfoto macht die Antwort ließ
nicht lange auf sich warten hier zum
Beispiel Scholz als piratenkanzler
so Volleyball EM in Italien da haben die
Männer einen guten Lauf im deutschen
drei Spiele drei Siege und vorzeitiger
Einzug ins Achtelfinale nach dem 13.2
Erfolg gestern Abend gegen Belgien ja
und das war echt ein hartes Stück Arbeit
denn das
DVV-Team das LAG 0:2 zurück dann aber
ein großartiges Comeback
es war weit mehr als nur ein Sieg für
die deutsche Mannschaft die in den
ersten beiden Sätzen von starken Belgien
dominiert wurde was dann passierte die
Niederlage vor Augen war wie ein Weckruf
für Trainer michaeliarski und sein Team
ein zunehmend variablerer Angriff dazu
ein bärenstarker Block und kaum mehr
eigene Fehler waren die
richtungsweisenden Kombination zu einem
harte kämpften drei zu zwei Erfolg über
Belgien nun kann sich das deutsche Team
freuen auf starke Serben morgen und am
Mittwoch auf italienische Weltmeister
Ankunft des DFB-Teams der Männer heute
Abend in Wolfsburg zur Vorbereitung auf
das erste von zwei Testspielen am
Samstag gegen Japan wieder dabei Thomas
Müller der heute von Trainer Hansi
fliegt wegen der leichten Verletzung von
BVB Stürmer Niklas Füllkrug
nachnominiert wurde
ja im Fußball oder auch in der leichter
Athletik da steht Deutschland
international zur Zeit ja gerade nicht
besonders gut da anders dagegen etwa im
Kanu oder Boxsport und ausgerechnet dort
drohen jetzt finanzkürzungen durch den
Bund der Spitzensport schlägt Alarm
das hier sollen die Kanus für Olympia in
Paris werden Maßanfertigungen vom FES
den Berliner Institut für Forschung und
Entwicklung von Sportgeräten einer
Goldschmiede des olympischen Sports nun
plant die Bundesregierung eine
drastische Budgetkürzung von 19%. das
ist auch ein Signal an Athleten das ist
eine macht was emotionales und wir haben
schon zu wenig Wertschätzung des
deutschen Sports in Deutschland und das
ist wieder ein Stück der einfach die
Frage stellt wofür machen wir das und
warum machen wir das eigentlich Bob
Rodel Kanu Rennrad dort wo das
Sportgeräte bei Siku Niederlage mit
entscheidet Ruhe eine Medaille Flaute so
die Warnung heute aus Berlin damit wird
noch die Chance auf eine mögliche
deutsche Olympia Bewerbung sinken man
wird nicht an ein Land Olympische Spiele
vergeben die ist gar nicht ernst meinen
denn jedes Land was ich beworben hat ja
hat gesagt jetzt mal investiert weil es
natürlich klar ist dass man nicht nur
guter Gastgeber sein will sondern man
will dort auch mit den Sportlern
erfolgreich abschneiden der Aufschrei
aus dem spitz ensport scheint gehört zu
finden das verantwortliche
Bundesinnenministerium signalisiert auf
zdf-anfrage es seien gerade Zitat
weitere Lösungsansätze für eine
auskömmliche Finanzierung des FS in
Abstimmung
das klingt ja schon mal gar nicht so
schlecht Lösungsansatz das Wetter bleibt
sonnig und warm die Details hat gleich
aus dem terli viertel vor zehn begrüßt
Sie Marietta Slomka im heute-journal
einen schönen Abend ihnen noch und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieses Hoch hier
sorgt bei uns für sehr ruhiges und sehr
sonniges Wetter aber auf seiner Ostseite
kommt hier Kaltluft bis in den
Mittelmeerraum voran und hier ist das
Meer sehr warm und somit gibt es hier
eine explosive Mischung hier werden
Regenmengen von 700 Liter auf den
Quadratmeter erwartet flächendeckend
punktuell kann es sogar über 1000 Liter
gehen also das ist ein Extremwetter
Ereignis was zu katastrophalen Folgen
führen wird Schlammlawine und
Überschwemmung werden die Folge sein bei
uns gibt's ruhiges Wetter teilweise
gibt's Nebel und sternenklaren Himmel
weitere Temperaturen von 9 Grad im
Südosten und 16 Grad ganz im Westen und
morgen Sonnenschein pur nur einige
harmlose Wolken im Osten Deutschlands
das bei Temperaturen um die 30 Grad
Marke entlang des Rheins 24 Grad an der
Nordsee das ist die Temperaturspanne die
nächsten Tage gibt es Sonnenschein pur
25 bis 31 Grad am Mittwoch Donnerstag
und Freitag geht's bis auf 32 Grad
hinauf und weiterhin viel Sonnenschein
ein schöner Abend